uno de los principales objetivos de la
contabilidad de caja es poder hacer
declaraciones de contabilidad y como
primer lugar es poder ir reflejando lo
que va ocurriendo a lo largo del negocio
y esto resulta bueno para aquellos que
quieran como un amplio panorama de cómo
se va realizando su negocio o puede ser
también para un gestor de negocios que
para ellos se pueda ir viendo
conscientemente cómo va el negocio de lo
que va funcionando o lo que no funciona
o también para ver cómo puede utilizar
mejor sus recursos para obtener mejores
ganancias entonces vamos a ver dos
métodos de contabilidad que serían el
método de efectivo o el método de
acumulación que este segundo nos va a
indicar a más grandes rasgos lo que va
pasando en cualquier momento del negocio
entonces lo azul que escribí lo primero
o la primera columna es el efectivo y la
segunda columna nos representa la
acumulación donde esta segunda será lo
que actualmente se va recibiendo o lo
que se va generando entonces si
observamos un poco el estado de
resultados si asumimos que viviéramos en
un mundo sencillo donde no hubiera que
pagar ni impuestos ni intereses
obviamente como una completa utopía pero
bueno con esto sólo tendríamos ingresos
y quizás uno que otro gasto asociado a
dicho ingreso entonces estos serán los
dos tipos de estados de resultados que
iremos usando durante cada mes por lo
que ahora en el segundo mes que estoy
señalando por aquí en nuestras bases de
contabilidad se puede observar que hay
200 dólares 200 dólares que los estuve
marcando como una perdida pero dicha
pérdida en cuanto al negocio si
recuerdas estamos aquí hablando de la
primera columna en la cual es la
contabilidad de caja pero si nos vamos
ahora la segunda tiene un muchísimo
mejor aspecto qué es lo que se va
acumulando exactamente entonces aquí en
esta columna como puedes ver hay
cuatrocientos dólares que se abonan por
así decirlo por el hecho de tú haber
prestado tus servicios de haber dado tu
atención a un cliente ya nosotros por
atender dicho evento nos va a costar 200
dólares los cuales al final nos van a
dejar un total de 200 dólares
y todo esto asumiendo que tu cliente
estuvo de acuerdo de pagar
dichos 400 dólares de hecho tú cada mes
puedes cobrarle una cierta cantidad a tu
cliente por estar activo y tú estás
prestando tus servicios y este dinero
que tú has ido recibiendo lo puedes
utilizar como un activo que sería algo
que te va generando ingresos los cuales
los puedes ocupar para ir generando
algún otro tipo de ganancias y al estar
cobrando dicho dinero es algo que los
contadores normalmente realizan por
estar brindando sus servicios y hasta lo
llegan a hacer con un mes por adelantado
pero bueno yo considero que la columna
de este lado la de acumulación como ya
lo he dicho en un inicio nos está dando
una mejor indicación de lo que realmente
está ocurriendo con nuestras ganancias
ahora yéndome al tercer mes en estas
bases de contabilidad podemos observar
como si el cliente no hubiera hecho nada
pero por el otro lado en la columna
acumulación esto luce como si fuese
nuestro mejor mes pues aquí tenemos 600
dólares de los cuales nosotros no
estamos atendiendo realmente a ningún
cliente lo cual nos está generando
ningún tipo de gasto pero en realidad no
es que tengamos como tanto dinero sino
que simplemente no hay gastos y en los
ingresos que se han ido acumulando
anterior del mes siguiente y estos 200
dólares se acaba subrayar aquí son en
nuestro cliente es lo que nos están
queriendo decir que sería como diferir
el dinero puesto que a él hay que
brindarle atención el siguiente mes y él
nos pagó por adelantado dicho dinero
como ya lo dije será como diferir el
ingreso puesto que si hay que reservar
para los clientes que vienen más
adelante finalmente aquí en este cuarto
mes subrayó estos 100 dólares porque
aquí ya todo cobra sentido aquí ya se
hizo el gasto de los 200 dólares por
brindar el servicio al cliente y
finalmente nos queda este residuo este
residuo de 100 dólares que es nuestra
real ganancia puesto que en la columna
anterior se aparece como algo negativo
es porque nosotros sabemos que nos está
desglosando tal cual como en el
acumulado y lo haré en el siguiente
vídeo